miles de afganos esperan en precarias
condiciones poder subirse a uno de los
aviones mientras observan desesperados
como la fecha límite de las
repatriaciones está cada vez más próxima
en el aeropuerto de kabul una botella de
agua se vende por 40 dólares un plato de
arroz por 100 dólares dólares no afganos
sino estadounidenses eso está fuera de
alcance de la gente común dólar de agua
ley de eeuu reiteró su intención de
cumplir con la retirada total de sus
tropas del 31 de agosto alegando que
esperan que el grupo talibán cumpla con
su frágil compromiso de permitir que los
civiles puedan abandonar afganistán
después de su salida forma desde mi
perspectiva y la del presidente estos
esfuerzos no terminarán el 31 de agosto
continuará durante todo el tiempo que
sea necesario para sacar de afganistán a
las personas que deseen marcharse where
to be desde a las peticiones de la
comunidad internacional y de algunos
demócratas el presidente joe biden se
mantiene firme en su decisión según la
casa blanca washington ha ayudado a
evacuar a más de 80.000 personas de la
capital afgana pero todavía no están
claros los procedimientos de asilo para
los miles de demandantes una vez sean
reubicados
una vez las personas lleguen a eeuu
serán elegibles para solicitar asilo u
otras vías de inmigración disponibles
que tengan como condición procesos de
selección servicios y procedimientos
adicionales entonces no no podemos
garantizar nada a nadie lee ann y
benítez
de una situación en la que podrían
rechazar algunas de estas solicitudes de
asilo y enviarlas de regreso a
afganistán no anticipó que ese sea el
plano durante una entrevista con el
medio español el país jens stoltenberg
secretario general de la otan declaró
que la misión de las tropas
internacionales durante la invasión
estadounidense era proteger a estados
unidos y no a afganistán